[Musique]
entre le premier ministre australien
scott morrison et jean yves le drian
c'est la guerre des mots il y a eu
mensonge il y a eu duplicité il y avait
eu rupture majeure de confiance mon il
ya eu un mépris donc ça ne va pas entre
nous ça ne va pas du tout quand on parle
d'allier même quand il s'agit d'une
trahison parce qu'il s'agit d'une
trahison on se garde des mouvements
d'humeur et on garde la tête froide donc
la france réagit trop vivement nous
comprenons la profonde déception
française mais il y avait eu une série
de problèmes sur l'exécution de ce
contrat que nous avions soulevé avec les
français à de nombreuses reprises des
australiens devront rouler dans la
farine ils ont menti la déclaration de
ce matin est un mensonge est ce que il y
a eu finalement des connaissances de la
part des services diplomatiques s qui a
également donné une défaillance est ce
qu à une négligence c'est pour cela
qu'avec mon groupe l'est républicain dès
mardi je demanderai en conférence des
présidents à ce qu'on puisse installer
une commission denquête c'est washington
en effet il semble qu'il n'ait jamais
été question de prévenir la france
d'abord parce que c'était le rôle de
l'australie selon les américains et
ensuite parce qu'il y avait la crainte
que la france fasse capoter cette
nouvelle alliance entre les trois pays
dans la zone indo pacifique byden fait
du trump et bien oui les etats-unis
défendent leurs intérêts mais ce qui est
un peu dramatique c'est que l'on soit
extrêmement naïf et qu'on le comprenne
que trop tard le président mbaye donne a
demandé à parler au président de la
république et il y aura un échange
téléphonique dans les tout prochains
jours entre le président maquereau et le
président mbaye donne la france n'a
certainement pas vocation à être traité
comme un valet comme un employé des
américains
certainement pas sur ce sujet là je
pense tout d'abord qu'il faut que le
président de la république s'exprime je
donnerai l'ordre immédiat mais immédiat
j'aurais pas rappelé l'ambassadeur du
blabla pour l'instant je n'oserais or
immédiat qu'on ne passe plus par des
entreprises américaines pour les
intérêts vitaux de l'état quoique le
président mitterrand avant de partir
parce que généralement la vérité est
toujours diffusée avant de partir pour
les responsables politiques disaient les
français sont en guerre contre
l'amérique mais ils ne le savent pas
encore tout ceci a commencé depuis
l'administration obama et ensuite avec
monsieur trump on est passé d'un
impérialisme d'isolationnisme un égoïsme
américain ne vous inquiétez pas ne vous
emballez pas ce n'est pas ce soir je
vais vous dire je suis candidat
pour l'instant la seule chose que j'ai
retenu c'est qu'il va falloir changer le
prénom des enfants ou interdire certains
prénoms voilà ce que géré quelques
exemples et vous quel comment vous
réagissez ces propositions alors moi je
m'appelle jordan ont manifesté je vais
te prennes jordan je suis fier de mon
prénom parce que contrairement à ce que
ce qu'a pu dire examu re jordan n'est
pas un marqueur culturel c'est un
marqueur social le pen ne sera pas au
deuxième tour parce qu'aujourd'hui eric
zemmour est un boulet à ses pieds et
eric zemmour est un boulet à ses pieds
aujourd'hui c'est le candidat de la
droite qui sera au deuxième tour et qui
battra emmanuel macron
sont donc qualifiés pour le second tour
et yannick jadot avec 27 70 % des voix
et sandrine rousseau avec
25,14 % des voix il ya des primaires à
peu près à peu près partout en ce moment
et donc est la volonté des candidats à
ces primaires de se démarquer voilà
madame pécresse elle a employé cette
phrase parce qu'elle savait que dans
l'émission du dimanche de bfm tv on la
diffuse réelles nous pensons qu'il ya
urgence pour le pays à ce que emmanuel
macron qui a été un président pour
presque rien et qui est en train de
cramer la caisse arrête son mandat en
2009 et dans le bureau du premier
ministre un premier ministre devenu
guide touristique pour quelques heures à
la grande surprise de son auditoire d'un
jour mais c'est trop facile ensuite de
se cacher derrière la coved pour
finalement ne plus maîtriser la dépense
et les déficits aujourd'hui en france ce
que nous disons c'est qu'on peut pas
être avoir la politique du carnet de
chèques permanente